wir wollen unsere unterhaltung in unsere
diskussion jetzt wolfgang kubicki
dazuholen bundestagsvize schön dass sie
bei uns sind herr kubicki wenn sie das
jetzt hören und auch das jetzt sehen die
entschuldigung die wir gerade
eingeblendet haben die da lautet das war
aus ästhetischen gründen und wir werden
das noch mal aufarbeiten und dann auch
wenn sie sehen was gemacht wurde also
dass der öffentlich-rechtliche mdr das
logo von bild einfach wegretuschiert
verfremdet wie sie ja selbst in der
entschuldigung dann dort sagen was geht
ihnen der rechen kopf
zunächst einmal mögen einige dass wir
eine petitesse alten ich glaube das ist
ein gravierender vorgang ist vor allen
dingen dem öffentlich rechtlichen
auftrag der sendeanstalten widerspricht
und zwar unmittelbar widerspricht sie
erklären der regelmäßig sie sind auch
darf oder fake news von news zu
unterscheiden und sie produzieren hier
selbst stellt news weil sie nicht die
wirklichkeit abbilden
die erklärung des synthetischen
unbeständigkeit kaum zu überbieten das
ist ja nicht mehr hinterher hier ist ja
auch beim bdr lebt noch in der sendung
ist angeblich ein bisschen stolz
magazins die wahlprogramme analysiert
haben festgestellt habe dass die freien
demokraten das haben die sanierte
klimaschutzprogramm haben und dann
anschließend erklärt haben dass laura
einfach nicht und die fdp nach hinten
durchgereicht haben auch das ist ja eine
form von fekters produktion man muss
vielleicht die redakteure trainieren das
ist ihre aufgabe zunächst darin besteht
die wirklichkeit abzubilden und dann zu
kommentieren nicht einfach als teil
einer aktionisten gruppe dabei zu sein
auf der sicheren seite die welt
verbessern zu wollen dass es nicht
aufgabe von journalisten lief es nicht
wirklich rechtlichen rundfunk sie
sprechen ja etwas anders sahen wir
gestern hier auch lange in der sendung
behandelt klagt das wissenschaftsmagazin
dass dann die fdp einfach so in einer
klimaschutz bewertung der programme nach
unten sortiert hat obwohl die fdp
eigentlich auf platz eins war nochmal
zusammengefasst wir bezahlen alle geld
da für sie müssen dafür geld bezahlen
und dann bekommen wir das geliefert wie
gefährlich ist das manipulierte
nachrichten der öffentlich rechtlichen
das ist gefährlich weil die
öffentlich-rechtlichen ja immer noch
ihre existenzberechtigung daraus
ableiten ihrem öffentlich rechtlichen
auftrag zu folgen wenn wir jetzt
mehrfach feststellen dass die
redaktionen diesen auftrag nicht genüge
tun dann schütten die nicht das
vertrauen in die lauterkeit dieser
ansteigen sondern dann wird eine der
begründungen für die aufrechte haltung
eine so umfangreiche und öffentlich
rechtlichen struktur schlicht und
ergreifend auch so lädt das müssen die
verantwortung ist sich jedes mal selbst
vor augen führen jeder weitere fall
dieser art dokumentiert das ist
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
offensichtlich die aufgabe von
journalisten völlig falsch verstanden
wird und die beitragszahler dann
irgendwann zu recht fragen warum
finanzieren wir die verbreitung von
macnews.de coupé bleiben sie den moment
bei uns wir holen noch den
cdu-landeschef in sachsen-anhalt dazu
sven schultze der uns zusätzlich
zugeschaltet des schönen guten tag herr
schulze
jetzt hören sie uns gerade noch nicht
oder hören sie mich besser wir probieren
sie einfach noch mal herr schulze sind
sie angekommen bei uns mal bild live
daher sind wirklich tun schwierigkeit
die basteln rumbasteln dann noch mal ein
bisschen dran aber herr kubicki vision
für ganz gut verstehen
ich kann sie ausgezeichnet ist verstehen
auch ausgezeichnet sehen und lassen sie
uns noch einmal irgendwelche klima
sprechen das war ja auch gerade ein
kritikpunkt von bildpolitik chef jan
schäfer der hier mit uns in der runde
ist also das klima das dort zu herrschen
scheint oder offenbar herrscht in dem
solche entscheidungen getroffen werden
wie das bild mikro zu übermalen
technisch zu übermalen so dass von bild
nicht mehr zu sehen ist kennen sie ein
solches klima
nein und ich schätze herrn schäfer sehr
aber ich würde nur dringend davor warnen
zu glauben dass die gedanken daran
schuld ist dass redakteure sich jetzt zu
aktivisten erklärten das ist ja kein wie
gesagt kein vorgang gehen der airline
die neben der lage betrifft das ist ja
in fast allen sendeanstalten wir haben
mittlerweile eine kategorie von
journalisten die glauben sie seien teil
der bewegung die welt zu verbessern sie
sagen wer aktivisten als wirklich
journalisten der auftrag aber der
flächen besteht nicht darin die menschen
zu erziehen sondern die möglichkeit
abzubilden und dann auch zu kommentaren
zu neigen und zu
meinungsbildungsprozesses beizutragen
aber jedenfalls nicht durch falsche
nachrichten durch die falsche wiedergabe
von wirklichkeit manipulativ in den bann
und mainz - prozess ein zu wollen herr
kubicki sie sprechen von wachsendem
aktivismus bei den öffentlich
rechtlichen sendern in wie weit ist der
öffentliche recht die rundfunk für sie
noch glaubwürdig
ja ich würde nicht so weit gehen dass
ihr sagen würde weil jetzt bei
bedauerlicherweise das mikrofon
reduziert worden ist halten sämtliche
beiträge aus mit dem anspruch auf
notwendigkeit daherzukommen ich glaube
schon dass er öffentlich rechtliche
rundfunk bbc übrigens auch dazu beiträgt
die meinung zu bilden aber wie gesagt
wir müssen aufpassen das ist ja kein
einzelfall ist verstärkt ist und gerade
bei der klimaschutz bewegung verstärkt
sich das und auch bei der 100 kaninchen
haben ja gesehen dass bestimmte
informationen einfach nicht her
transportiert werden ausgeblendet werden
noch einmal wir müssen aufpassen
ansonsten besteht der öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk zu unrecht darauf
dass er und verfassungs wegen garantiert
seine meinung und außerdem
berichterstattung in unters volk bringen
können die glaubwürdigkeit frage wollen
wir jetzt noch mal probieren zu
diskutieren auch mit sven schulze cdu
landeschef in sachsen anhalt denn das
war ja auch in ihrem wahlkampf in diesem
jahr ein erhebliches thema als es um die
rundfunkgebühren gegen die zusätzliche
erhöhungen sachsen anhalt besonders
kritisch begleitet die glaubwürdigkeit
des mdr des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks sind wie weit trägt ja ein
solcher fall eine
manipulation des bildes dort gestern im
sachsenspiegel dazu bei diese
glaubwürdigkeit weiter anzukratzen
sie sind mit master battle können sie
auch wenn der ton ist nicht optimal aber
wir versuchen es einfach das ist
natürlich was man da sieht die kann man
nicht einfach mal so abtun und sagen das
ist ein fehler eines einzelnen personen
gewesen weil das genau was wir jetzt
erleben weil das kratzt massiv an der
genauigkeit und ich hatte auch schon
kontakt mit
deutschen und co
ich glaube da ist man höchst alarmiert
man sieht dass du was natürlich nicht
passieren darf und gerade hier in
sachsen anhalt im jahr vor einigen
wochen auch das urteil zur kenntnis
genommen haben wir gesagt wie wichtig
der öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk john
kelly vom feld muss ist wie wichtig die
aufgabe des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks auch ist aber dass man halt
wirklich die wahrheit darstellt dann ist
das ist natürlich jetzt hier ein zeichen
dass man nicht einfach damit erklären
kann dass irgendein mitarbeiterin
mitarbeiter oder eine mitarbeiterin da
irgendwie was reduziert hat aus
ästhetischen gründen das ist so nicht
glaubwürdig was glauben sie was macht
das mit den zuschauern und zuschauern
die sich darauf verlassen dass sie die
wahrheit abgebildet bekommen etwas was
sich die öffentlich-rechtlichen ja auch
auf die fahne geschrieben haben völlig
zurecht auch das ist ja der große
standard den man erfüllen muss aber
gerade wenn das alles auch noch
finanziert ist von den zuschauerinnen
und zuschauern selbst was macht das dann
mit denen die einschalten und jetzt zum
wiederholten male etwas sehen müssen was
der wahrheit nicht entspricht
jetzt ist wenn man weiß das ist wasser
auf
wir haben das alles erzähle ja nicht
dahingehend gemacht wie es hier in
ostdeutschland nach dem was man sagt man
muss die richtigen abschaffen sondern
wir haben
und wir haben auch mal einzelne
beispiele gebracht die vielleicht in der
vergangenheit nicht positiv liefen und
das was man daher zieht das ist
natürlich für viele vielleicht eine
kleinigkeit aber es ist irgendwo auch
ein zeichen warum setzt sich denn jemand
hin
dort arbeitet und reduziert da ein rotes
mikrofon weg beziehungsweise dass das
nur oder bild -zeitung raus aber das ist
natürlich auch für diejenigen grad in
der bevölkerung die sagen wir haben da
bedenken ob der öffentlich rechtliche
rundfunk immer ganz objektiv berichtet
ist das ein klares indiz dass da was
nicht richtig ist und ich glaube da das
hilft am ende auch nicht mit einer
entschuldigung und entehrt angekündigt
heute abend in der sendung züchter auch
für zu entschuldigen noch einmal halt
ich glaube dass jetzt gefordert ist auch
eine klare
eingebunden im öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk warum sowas immer wieder
passiert aber er schulte dann machen wir
es noch mal ganz konkret also wenn sie
sagen es muss ergründet werden was genau
muss dann eigentlich passieren sie haben
auch gerade von reformvorschlägen für
den öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
gesprochen dann machen sie doch mal
konkret was aus ihrer sicht muss jetzt
geschehen
zwei dinge nicht vermischen wenn wir was
man in der politik über vorgesprochen
haben dann geht es nicht um die inhalte
und da geht es jetzt auch nicht um
solche beispiele heute ihr sondern
grundlegend die situation ist öffentlich
richtig und in gensingen ganz
deutschland was war jetzt hier sehen ist
auch eine situation dass man sich jetzt
fragen muss warum kommt jemand auf die
idee dass überhaupt zu machen brauchen
macht sich jemand die mühe also etwas
reduziert das macht man ja nicht weil
man irgendwo meint man hat langeweile
und muss das jetzt aber das ist
ästhetisch besser aussieht und die
zweite frage ist warum arbeiten dort
leute die nicht erkennen was ich damit
am ende dort verursachen ich sag mal das
ist jetzt schon ein riesengroßer skandal
zumindest auf dieser lokalen ebene des
ndr nicht weiß auch dass die
verantwortlichen ist aber mir sind auch
verärgert dass das überhaupt so passiert
ist das heißt man muss auch die
mitarbeiter sensibilisieren und sagen
und man muss sich die frage stellen
warum kommt denn jemand überhaupt auf
die idee und erkennt nicht was man damit
anrichtet auch wenn es ihr ziel in
anführungsstrichen nur um einen
reduzieren eines bildes gehen aber
dieses symbol was damit aus geht es ist
schon sehr sehr gravierend glaubens
letzte frage an wolfgang kubicki fdp
bundestags vizepräsident was machen wir
jetzt mit dem fall das muss jetzt
passieren im mdr
finde ich die erklärung des mdr dass er
sie verbreitet deshalb ästhetischen
gründen geschehen nicht nur peinlich
sondern eigentlich einen weiteren
skandal denn das mikrofon ist geblieben
also brot und rot denn der ist ethisch
überhaupt nichts gemacht worden hier
können wir darüber nachdenken aber die
tatsache dass er das einfach so
verbreitet und nicht dem nachgehen und
sata war einer der einfacher weil ja die
bild -zeitung schrecklich und von mir
das bild leicht schrecklich und deshalb
heute ja nicht dass es so gut drauf ist
das wenn erklärung mit der man leben
könnte dann müsste man die abmahnenden
mitarbeiter und sagen beim nächsten mal
bist du draußen ein freund aber dass er
in der er selbst eine solche wirklich
kinder erklärung nach schickt das finde
ich ist die peinlichkeit die dann eine
weitere aufführung bedarf die intendanz
oder eine redaktion eine solche meldung
verbreiten können das erschließt sich
mir nicht in das zeigt ja dass
offensichtlich die verantwortlichen die
brisanz der sache nicht erkannt haben
mit einer entschuldigung sei es bitter
danke an den fdp bundestags
vizepräsidenten wolfgang kubicki unter
an den cdu landeschef in sachsen-anhalt
sven schultze
[Musik]